we are down to our last four available
ventilators this is my lucky day
hi i'm annie onishi annie is a trauma
surgeon based in bend oregon
today i'm back critiquing medical scenes
in tv and movies
gunshot wound john wick punctured
i went deep the artery
so this doctor person is saying this
bullet
nicked the artery nick the artery if it
nicked the artery you would expect some
sort of arterial hemorrhage
you don't just sew up the skin of a
gunshot wound that's not how you
treat gunshot wounds if you close the
skin over an arterial injury you're
going to develop what's called a
hematoma so a giant collection of
blood as this thing continues to
actively bleed so the treatment for a
gunshot wound is not just to close the
skin it's to go in and
address whatever's been damaged john
wick excommunicado
in effect in three
two one i could definitely close
something if i had to
with a time countdown going on in fact i
do that on a daily basis for example the
cafeteria is going to close or i really
have to go to the bathroom
john wick is doing a great job it's
probably really hard to sew
looking at a mirror that's called uh
working backwards
the only reason i don't bite sutures
because i'm usually wearing a mask
mr wick
you'll never believe i stopped on the
hour where
here you should not hit my leg
all right be sure not to graze my car
those are not good spots to elect to be
shot in if i had to have somebody shoot
me i would definitely have them shoot me
below the knee
it's a very easy place to get a
tourniquet on these two places are
really bad
lower quadrant abdominal gunshot wounds
are really bad destructive gunshot
injuries to that structure
will make you end up with the colostomy
bag and then here he's shot
right under the left clavicle so that's
where the subclavian vein and artery
run that is notoriously difficult to fix
often involves actually removing the
clavicle really really poor choice
of elective gunshot wound good luck mr
wick
a colonoscopy in uncut gems
you scatter diverticular there
heading towards the splenic flexion now
yep that's what a colonoscopy looks like
but it looks like they've got a couple
things wrong here
i don't want to talk about it he says a
couple of colon sounding words a little
bit out of order and there's the
ileocecal valve blowing up the sigmoid
colon
you scatter diverticular there the
endoscopist puts the camera in
as far as they can go to the ileocecal
valve which is the
first part of your colon and once
they're all the way at the end of the
colon
they slowly withdraw you would see the
ileocecal valve you'd see the ascending
colon the hepatic flexure
transverse colon splenic flexure
descending and sigmoid i don't know if
that's an editing
issue or maybe he's doing his
colonoscopy backwards i'm not sure i
disagree
waking up for surgery er carter
carter wake up yeah jsw to the head
coming in ben's in surgery and gerry's
got a near mind
he's taking a nap in an unused either
looks like a recess bay
or an operating room there are plenty of
other more reasonable places to sleep in
the hospital for doctors
we always have a call room it's usually
very sad and depressing
windowless like you could probably reach
out and touch both walls but it's quiet
it's dark it's got a phone it's got a
computer everything you could need
everywhere i've ever worked has either a
phone or a pager system
you can't miss the alarm when a trauma's
coming in i've never had to be woken up
by another person
carter what let's go carter gets brought
some ppe that yellow gown to put on
nobody ever brings you ppe that is a
every woman for herself kind of thing
two large boy ivs fifteen meters oh two
vp's fifty plus fifty six gc
say a couple doctor-sounding words here
one is cyanotic
that refers to when a patient is uh
losing oxygen levels and they start to
actually turn blue
[Music]
okay is it the membrane horizontal
vertical horizontal no no a vertical
skin
incision first two things are accurate
about this one is vertical skin incision
so we make a vertical skin incision of
the cricothyroid membrane so if you feel
your
thyroid cartilage in a man that's the
adam's apple
below that you'll start to feel the
cricoid cartilage in between that is a
small dent that is a little
membrane called the cricothyroid
membrane that's a great place to pop in
an emergency airway if for some reason
you can't intubate from the top
here's some hollywood makeup
demonstrating a bunch of orofacial
trauma
tosses 54. tried to integrate him but
there was too much blood and tissue
including his airwaves just about to
start a quicker thigh right now
all right i think this kid looks
intubatable just looking at him you can
see his cheek is kind of blown off but
his actual mouth itself looks okay
and importantly the sort of the
structures of the oral fairings in the
neck don't look affected by this injury
so
we don't jump straight to a crack we at
least take one or two good college tries
at an oral tracheal intubation just
because that is safer and easier
i hope medical malpractice covers this
the heimlich maneuver in mrs doubtfire
i think the most important thing to do
when someone's choking is first have
somebody else
call 9-1-1 that way while you're helping
the person who's choking some real
professional help could be on the way
help is on the way here
this is exactly what i shout when i'm
paige to the emergency room
one more time mrs doubtfire is doing
a really excellent heimlich maneuver
here your landmarks are right underneath
the rib cage you can sort of feel where
the ribs come
up and under it's a two-handed kind of
thrust and a j-shaped motion
you do that until the object is
ejected virtual reality test run in the
good doctor
let's take them off bypass what they
have is a three-dimensional model of the
patient's
specific anatomy and they are planning
their approach to
fixing whatever the problem is here
his outflow is perfect at 13 millimeters
which is irrelevant the mitral valve
doesn't have enough support to close
all the technical surgery anatomy words
they're using is essentially nonsensical
but the technology and the idea of using
vr to prep for a surgery is definitely
real
simulation is definitely a part of
surgical education these days
we have entire rooms that are pretend
operating rooms they look like operating
rooms they sound like operating rooms
they got all the monitors
we can run whole simulations with
different teams so we can practice
crisis situations in an operating room
robot assisted surgery grey's anatomy
oh no you did not oh yes i did
the da vinci sihd surgical system
general surgeons do not get that excited
about the robot this is not
an instrument that we use routinely it
is more
used by colorectal surgeons ob gyn
doctors and urology doctors
feels pretty good doesn't it
one major advantage of robotic surgery
is these so-called degrees of motion
so if you actually look at the end of
these robot arms they move like a wrist
and a hand
it's basically like your real hand but
working in a tiny tiny space
this is a big advantage over laparoscopy
so laparoscopy
uses just long instruments that can only
move in certain planes because it's a
long basically stick
dr bailey are you making life safer
noises
[Music]
not anymore this is what the screen
really does look like
the view in the console is much more
three dimensional and realistic that's a
big difference between
robotic surgery and laparoscopy you may
have seen this demo video where they're
doing robotic surgery on a grape these
are the da vinci people trying to show
how delicate and precise the robotic
surgical technology can be
i mean can you peel a grape with this
amount of precision
let me retract that small bowel so
you'll have better visualization
i think the major misconception that the
public has about robotic surgery is that
the robot is actually doing the surgery
that's not the case
the surgeon is still doing the surgery
the job of a surgeon is not going
anywhere we're not being replaced by
robots the robotic
surgical platform is just that it's a
tool rebar injury
[Music]
all right can you move not a bit this is
accurate because
if a patient is impaled on anything the
recommendation is not to remove that
object
that object may be stopping major
life-threatening hemorrhage
so we need to transport the patient with
the object impaled to an operating room
where it can be removed under controlled
circumstances
let's get to our three prep for a
decompressive hemi craniotomy it's
pretty reasonable this guy would need a
hemi craniectomy or a hemi
that refers to the removal of half of
the skull flap in order to
evacuate blood control
[Music]
that damage doesn't quite look like what
a cranictomy incision would look like
the way you get the
skull off is you connect a bunch of
little dots that are made with a little
drill and then the
thing pops right off and it makes that
noise
the angle of that rebar looks like it's
crossing the midline it's going in on
this side of his forehead and looks like
it's coming out the back
i don't imagine that this patient will
be talking but again stranger things
have happened
once you are totally prepared in the
operating room yes you would just have
to eventually just take the rebar out
here in the background it looks like
they made a pit stop in the ct scanner
before they zipped up to the or
and their radiologist made some really
beautiful and real-to-life
3d reconstructions of the guy's head and
this piece of rebar
we do actually have these really amazing
3d models that can be made
to help you visualize an injury holy
crap
another rebar injury in sirens six feet
of rebar goes right through me
and then i'm like holy tim you see this
and then carl runs over and he's all see
what and then
boom carl's out cold i have seen some
patients
after the shock of an accident ignore
some
insane injuries this looks like some
pretty bad
penetration here your liver your kidney
your colon
the main thing i would be worried about
here is your inferior vena cava which is
a
giant vein about that big we're gonna
have to take you to the hospital
mike it's bad it's really bad are you
kidding me
this is my lucky day adrenaline will
keep people growing even if they're
gravely injured
testing a patient's orientation stranger
things
this doctor is checking will's pupillary
reflexes it's just kind of a
basic neuro exam just to make sure all
the
circuits are linked up do you know your
name will
your full name william byers
you know do you know who i am if we're
gonna try to assess a patient's
orientation i don't usually go into this
amount of detail especially if they've
had some head trauma i would start with
what's your name
what's today's date and what is this
place
now will i want you to just let us know
if you feel anything
okay
[Music]
i don't know if any hospital that allows
blow torches inside of them there's a
lot of reasons not to have compressed
gas in a hospital environment
how about now it burns
where you can hear in the background
will's heart rate is going up that's
that high-pitched beeping sound
where i certainly would imagine if you
held the blow torch to
a patient's limb they would have some
tachycardic response
as a stress response and as a response
to pain abdominal stab wound
we have to stop the bleeding this looks
like a pretty grievous injury
you can see the amount of blood that's
immediately pouring out we're going to
catch up
see how pale he gets pretty quickly
in the early 20th century with limited
access to antibiotics iv
fluids surgical care and good post-op
care i think
nine times out of ten this would have
been a lethal wound let's just sit
let me sit we can't we have to find a
second remember
i would just recommend if your buddy
gets stabbed out in the field just do
your best
try to stuff some gauze into that hole
and just hold direct pressure until help
can come when a patient comes in to
recess
having bled out a bunch they are white
as a ghost no matter what their skin
tone is
they're drenched in sweat and they just
they got this crazy look in their eye
it's called the fight-or-flight response
who should i
one thing that hollywood does
notoriously badly is these scenes of
young men dying of hemorrhagic shock
where they're lying they're all
angelic and wishing for their mom that's
not what happens to them they go down
swinging the body is just
totally amped up on adrenaline when
you're bleeding out you can't hold them
down
they're crazy they're strong they're
they're waving their arms around it
takes four people to hold them down then
their heart stops now i'm going to talk
about how medical shows have covered the
covet 19 respiratory pandemic
patient and respiratory failure chicago
med
mr booker i'm afraid your x-ray looks
white
he says the x-ray looks wet i 100
disagree the most
important thing i see are big lung
fields and sharp costophrenic angles
what that tells me is this patient is
able to take big deep breaths
they have a lot of capacity to aerate
their lungs
those sharp costophrenic angles which is
the angle between
the ribs and the diaphragm that's nice
and sharp meaning the patient's nice and
dry they're not
fluid overloaded the airways themselves
you can kind of see
some hazy stuff bilaterally on both
sides that that we would call that an
infiltrate i don't feel that bad
and the thing that makes people feel bad
a rise in co2 doesn't happen with covert
that's false cova 19 causes both
hypoxemic and hypercarbic respiratory
failure which means the lungs can't do
anything they can't bring oxygen in they
can't get carbon dioxide out so what now
i suggest we innovate and put you on a
ventilator i would not intubate this guy
based on what i know right here which is
limited we don't intubate based on an
x-ray
an x-ray is a piece of the puzzle one
thing that we discovered early on in the
pandemic was
that the amount of support that cova 19
patients need from the ventilator
requires so much airway pressure to be
delivered from the machine that the
ventilator was actually
hurting the patient's lungs so as
time went on over the spring and summer
we really started dragging our feet on
intubation
basically with this patient um yeah he
sort of sounds like he's not doing
awesome i would be willing to give this
guy some more time if we wait
and you go into cardiac arrest we can't
resuscitate you you know it's terrible
but we can't run a coat in here chest
compressions release
so much virus i wish we couldn't code
patients with covid but that's
absolutely not the case we've definitely
been doing chest compression cpr
defibrillations on patients with kovid
100 that's called aerosolizing procedure
meaning it generates you know bajillions
of that's the medical term bajillions of
um aerosolized particles containing the
virus but
with everybody in ppe uh yes we were
absolutely coding uh coveted patients
20 of atomic 800 a rock 20 of atominate
and 100 of rock that is a pretty
standard medication regimen for
intubation so you give
a slug of a tominate the patient falls
asleep and then you paralyze with a
hundred of rock uronium so that's a
medication that um just completely
paralyzes every muscle in the body and
allows you to get the breathing tube in
ventilator shortages grey's anatomy as
of five o'clock this morning we are down
to our last four available ventilators
so until relief arrives i need us all to
think creatively
it's very nice that these people have
enough time every morning to have a
little staff meeting where they can talk
about their resources
in real life in my experience in two
hospitals during the coveted pandemic
this
type of information would be discussed
by sort of the suit types and then
disseminated via an email
okay come on this lady looks like she's
in trouble so she's already wearing high
flow nasal cannula which is a pretty
aggressive form of respiratory support
it delivers a
very high degree of inspired oxygen the
other thing you see her doing is leaning
forward
that's called tripoding that is a sign
of respiratory distress and impending
collapse ventilators are our last resort
put them on bypass the hyperbaric
chamber uh pronane let's exhaust all
options first here you hear the chiefs
naming all the different other
strategies besides intubation in order
to support somebody in respiratory
failure
this is a spectrum but they're all not
mutually exclusive meaning
yes the first thing we start with is a
simple nasal cannula that's what you
sort of always see in hollywood it's
that thin tubing that sits right here
on your face the next level up from
nasal cannula is something called a
simple mask and then a non-rebreather
mask
that delivers inspired oxygen to the
whole nasopharynx and the oral pharynx
the nanobreather is what pops down from
the ceiling of an airplane in the event
of an emergency the next
level up would be something called high
flow nasal cannula
that's what this lady is wearing that is
able to deliver
very very high flows of very very
concentrated and humidified oxygen to
really boost somebody's oxygen levels
the next thing after that prior to
intubation is something called bipap
which is a mask that is sealed to the
face and actually gives the patient some
positive pressure meaning the machine is
actually pushing air
and oxygen into the patient's lungs and
then finally after that would be
intubation
[Music]
check that patent cuff tube ready
so this cowboy is going to intubate
without medication so as opposed to the
other doc who asked for atomic and rock
uranium
20 of atomic 800 rock this guy is just
gonna
intubate her without any sedation or
paralytic um that's actually really
difficult without a patient being
paralyzed ecmo in my favorite
the good doctor dr lim can you hear me
oh two stats are still dropping
we got a whole bunch of tricks up our
sleeve to help somebody
between nasal cannula and when they
arrest like this these
doctors sort of miss the boat on other
forms of respiratory support
we put her on ecmo oxygenate her blood
outside her body
their very brief explanation of ecmo is
correct ecmo stands for extracorporeal
membrane oxygenation
it's for patients in severe severe
respiratory failure
getting a patient accumulated onto ecmo
is not a one-person job blood is removed
from circulation
passed through an oxygenator where
oxygen is delivered to the blood and
then
passed over a membrane where carbon
dioxide is removed from the blood
basically doing the entire job of the
lungs
like this lady says we take her lungs
out of the equation we put her on ecmo
oxygenate her blood outside her body her
lungs will have time to heal
i can't do ecmo in the er we aren't
supposed to do abdominal surgery in er
either
please walk me through it first of all
ecmo is not a thing that you get walked
through
okay ecmo is a very complex medical
intervention that requires the expertise
of somebody who really knows how to
first of all put it in second of all
run it you gotta have a perfusionist at
the bedside who knows what the machine
is doing and who knows how to
troubleshoot all the various components
and it's not something you can just like
do on the fly like it's i'm sure i
guarantee you that no
er has all the components for ecmo just
lying around
all the places i've worked that have
been ecmo centers have entire ecmo
closets that need to get mobilized in
the event that a patient needs to crash
onto ecmo this is just completely
off i this is just not something that
would happen that's just not how ecmo
works
push paralytics starting innovation
and here they go again pushing
paralytics without sedatives that would
mean is that the patient is completely
paralyzed cannot move a single muscle in
their body but they're potentially still
awake
that is a nightmare come true big no no
black market organs
riverdale
oh my god is that yes that doesn't look
like anything human
i think it's pretty common in hollywood
for them to use bovine or
cow organs to me it looks like a beef
heart normally i would immediately say
no
transplanted organs they come on sterile
ice
wrapped in two separate little plastic
baggies in a box and a box and a box and
a cooler
here's another clip from futurama
you want to buy organ fresh and cheap
ready for transplant that's a really
beautiful piece of colon that's the
eyeball
think that's gonna be a stomach looks
like a heart
yeah there's some good stuff do you take
cash i think it's probably pretty
difficult to keep these organs
alive perfused and sterile in this man's
smelly jacket
hypothermia in the fall what's going on
here she's hypothermic
core temp 28.2 paramedics got a line in
and i got some blood from what i put in
where was she finding in a forest in the
bit of a car
we think she was there for at least four
days this patient has severe hypothermia
from exposure
you can hear them explain that she was
stuck in the
the trunk of a car for a few days her
core temperature is
28 degrees that is extreme hypothermia
your body temperature runs about 36
37 those patients would be
hemodynamically unstable they would have
poor blood pressure probably very slow
heart rate they would have a lot of
organ damage
they wouldn't look as stable as this
girl looks
i can smell pair drops what are her
ketones 2.3
we can't move her until an icu bed is
ready and attempts going in the right
direction
so here he's reporting um the odor of
pear drops that's sort of the what
sounds like the irish or english version
of what we would describe as a fruity
odor when patients are
starving they haven't eaten in three
four days they start going into what's
called ketosis
when your body doesn't have enough
glucose to burn it starts burning other
amino acids and proteins and a byproduct
of that is ketones
so ketones can be detected in the blood
in the urine and exhaled gas
so classically a patient in ketosis will
have this fruity odor about them
a leg laceration and jewelry sutures the
shallows
not gonna feel the stitches okay
we have a surfer who's been injured here
from what i can see this is merely a
flesh wound
this does not look very serious i would
put a little pressure on that
maybe wrap that in a t-shirt head on
home and take a shower and get it
cleaned up
you absolutely would not be able to get
through your skin
with a piece of jewelry like that she
should just relax take a couple deep
breaths hold some pressure
and head on home a deaf patient in
switched at birth
why haven't you told her what's going on
she's completely confused
she's deaf she needs an interpreter
can you do it this is really poor form
here this
patient um has no interpreter at her
bedside to help her navigate this scary
trauma situation
and the healthcare provider here is
relying on the patient's friend to
interpret sign language
what's going on why isn't there an
interpreter here we're working on it
so medical interpreting is a very
specific field we have a
really great ipad on wheels thing it's a
big
screen that you roll up right to the
patient you can pick any language it
scrolls for like four or five pages to
to pick a language there's a lot of
specific training it's many hours it's
not just translating it's interpreting
there's a difference
so you really should not be using
friends or family members to help a
patient understand what's going on there
are no
doctors or nurses here that know sign
language
all right well there should be
conclusion
well we've looked at a lot of scenes
today i know a lot of this is for
dramatic effect but sometimes it's
pretty fun to look at what's well done
and what's not so well done
you